well let's take a look at tristan
mckenzie first overall he'll be making
his 20th start but at home this will be
start number nine he's one and one with
a 440 er8 it doesn't seem like much but
earlier in the year they weren't
pitching up deep enough but he's gone
out there you can see the opposition
batting average just a 173 against him
arise down on strikes
well a tough guy to strike out
but he comes back inside i mean that's a
good pitch
right on the inside corner
rise couldn't catch up with it and
tristan gets his first strikeout to the
first batter
that's swinging a miss
he quickly disposes of byron buxton and
tristan mckenzie strikes out the first
two yeah they're seeing a little
different mckenzie than they saw earlier
in the year and in the past
yes he did he went around and tristan
mckenzie strikes out the side to start
the ball game for twin starter young joe
ryan five innings in his major league
career and quitting himself very well
and the old two swing and a miss and
down he goes as rosario chase the
breaking ball so a slider erases rosario
and there is joe's sixth major league
strikeout jeffers drops a knee to the
ground and the 1-1 pitch a fly ball
playable
shallow left ref snyder in polanco out
polanco the shortstop calls and catches
and that's on number three so ryan with
a one two three first stitch
josh donaldson in the box
a high fly left field
ramirez back drifting back at the wall
and he made the catch harold ramirez up
against the left field wall
donaldson is going to stay at second
until the twins take a look at it
take a look see if you can see it hit
the wall
first
yes
right in the hook of the end
safe at second so we are glad now for
replay
and the 2-2 slowed it down
and a weak number up the first base line
mckenzie will take it himself that'll
boy make sure you catch that on the
backhand as you're running the first
base he did did a nice job donaldson
gets the third
broken bat and they got him picked at
third mackenzie runs him down and tags
it himself might have been able to get a
double play two down yeah when you get
that uh
he was going on contact and we mentioned
that
donaldson with his calf problems he
doesn't run well
all right i pop
shallow right
mckenzie decides to let some of his
other defenders do a little work
breaking ball bounced at third a rise
from foul territory and
in time to get him not much on the throw
and sono had to reach out for it but
arise's throw was on target for the out
the terrific play by a rise there to be
able to throw the ball on target when
you're that your body is that far out of
position
where he goes from here he's going to
depend on that pitch right there harold
ramirez is convinced another one two
three innings man's pitched seven in the
big leagues and six of them have been
one two three
nick gordon leads off for minnesota here
third inning no score he swings at the
first pitch lines at the center and a
great catch by bradley zimmer he came
racing in went to a slide and held on
for route number one good jump on the
ball that's what enabled him to catch
that thing and he never quit on it
and if we don't and if we do we'll give
it away swing and a miss down goes
jeffers that's four strikeouts for
mckenzie first time through the order
only one hit allowed
2-2 strike three call down the middle in
93 lavarnway kept the bat on his
shoulders third strikeout for ryan eight
up eight down
change up it's a weak fly ball to left
nice change nine up nine down for ryan
and that is strike three called fastball
paint outside corner oh man five k's for
mackenzie
and that's sucked deep right field
johnson makes the catch and then turns
and polanco lost sight of the play it's
a double play the inning is over he just
figured the ball was over his head he
was going to score i i don't understand
it but they certainly will take it
and a swing and a miss elevated fastball
and jimenez you strike out victim number
four
and that is for the hitters as well
the left field it's not easy but he's
making it look easy nine major league
innings and eight one two three
now ref snyder
and
[ __ ] the box but nowhere near the target
it's a two out walk and the first one
issued by either pitcher that'll get
nick gordon to the play
and in the dirt with res schneider
stealing second trying to get into
scoring position and he did so
successfully
and gordon drives a base hit to right
field he comes through with another
clutch two-out hit ref snyder will score
and the twins take the first lead
mr clutch nick gordon well he's hot he's
been swinging it really well
on the ground
arrives boots up recovers still got it
five perfect innings for joe ryan
buxton back
six
perfect innings for joel ryan
and a one-nothing twins lead
two down and now sano
to center and hit well hit very well and
gone ceno
hits one into the bullpen number 25 and
the twins take a two to nothing lead you
balanced it into the plaza area up there
that ball was a rocket there was no
doubt as soon as he hit it you could
tell by the extension and the sound it's
hard in watching how he's pitched it's
hard to convince yourself this is just
his second major league start
base hit that breaks it up after
retiring the first 19 batters the
hottest hitter for cleveland ahmed
rosario lines a sharp single to left a
little bit too much of a plate on that
slider than what he would like it wasn't
an awful pitch
too bad that that no hit bid
has to end
right field to kepler
another zero seven shutout innings just
one hit allowed what a night for joe
ryan
that'll bring up ryan jefferson
hard to the gap in left center field
and that'll get to the warning track and
to the wall jeffers to second has got a
double with one out here in the eighth
well now we'll see if a rise can deliver
a big hit
to the twins third baseman slash to left
there's the base head jeffers to third
and he'll be held up and no run scoring
on the play but a rise again with
another late inning head first and third
one down and now buxton
bouncer toward the hole they'll get one
and no chance buxton will stay out of
the double play and get a run batted in
and jumper jeffers does come in from
third and we have a three nothing lead
and that will leave it up to andres
jimenez
near perfection tonight in cleveland
and joel ryan gets his first major
league win
the bullpen
again steps up to finish it off
and the twins have back-to-back
three-nothing wins over cleveland